Sometimes all it takes is one terrifying moment
to elevate a horror movie from flash-in-the-pan
fun to a must-see movie.
A single scene can make the difference between
a movie that comes and goes without much fanfare
and one that makes its way into cinematic
history.
These films managed to make moments that are
not only unforgettable, but ones which viewers
might not be so eager to revisit.
Elevator down
Ti West's modern horror masterpiece, The House
of the Devil, is a quiet, tense film—right
up until its infamous ending.
The movie surrounds Samantha, a babysitter
who reluctantly agrees to keep an eye on a
couple's bedridden mother.
Predictably, the night doesn't quite go as
planned.
But while the film as a whole is suspenseful
and masterful in its building of tension,
it's the finale that makes it all pay off:
a spectacularly terrifying satanic ritual
and chase scene featuring blood, guts and
the reveal of a horrifically deformed grandmother,
the matriarch of a devil-worshipping cult.
The end is relentless.
It hits the viewer like a freight train and
doesn't slow its momentum for a second.
You'll be out of breath by the time it's over
and likely not anxious to revisit it any time
soon.
A close shave
Eli Roth tends to excel at nausea-inducing
moments, largely involving gore and mutilation,
and while his filmography is chock-full of
gut-churning nastiness, there's something
about the brutal simplicity of his debut film,
Cabin Fever.
The scene in question involves one of the
characters shaving her legs.
The catch?
Well, the plot of the movie revolves around
some 20-somethings in the woods who are exposed
to a flesh-eating virus.
So as she shaves her legs, her flesh is peeling
from the bone, piece by piece.
It's both repulsive and enthralling, and you'll
probably never want to watch it again.
Discovering the tapes
Few scary movies have utilized sound scares
quite as well as the psychological horror
juggernaut Session 9.
The film takes place in an abandoned mental
asylum and shows how the lingering spirits
affect a group of men who are there to refurbish
the building.
One of the men, Mike, discovers a cache of
tape recordings of therapy sessions with a
patient suffering from dissociative identity
disorder, who also might also be possessed.
These tapes play throughout the film, but
it's that first scene that stands out as the
film's creepiest moment.
The squeal of the tape, the moment the voices
appear, everything about it is masterfully
executed.
As soon as the voices start, the viewer knows
something is wrong.
Something bad is going to happen as the sessions
move closer and closer to the titular session
nine.
"Mary?"
"Have you seen the doll Mr. Doctor?"
The scene doesn't jump out at you.
It doesn't feature a gory dismemberment.
But it's creepy to the point that viewers
will want to avoid it upon any future revisiting
of the film.
The sloth
David Fincher's Se7en features a number of
gruesome mutilations, but choosing its standout
doesn't feature dismemberment or decapitation.
It simply features a man left to rot.
The film's villain had chained the victim
for a year and simply never let him move,
doing just enough to keep him alive for a
long enough time to allow his body to waste
away.
The makeup is horrifying, creating an image
of a man who looks like something other than
human.
It's a nauseating sight to behold, which is
exactly what it should be.
And it's all capped off with the reveal that
the victim is still alive.
In a film full of horrific imagery and dark
plot turns, the Sloth victim is the hardest
moment to endure more than once.
It doesn't have the tense narrative turns
of the film's grim ending.
It doesn't need to.
It's horrifying enough on premise alone.
Night vision
The Descent is an exercise in unrelenting
horror, and while the whole film may be difficult
to dive into more than once, the night vision
scene in particular is almost too terrifying
to screen twice.
The film features a group of friends on a
caving trip who find themselves hunted by
a group of cave-dwelling mutants.
The film does a great job of keeping the creatures
hidden until the perfect moment.
Already thriving on claustrophobia and fear
of the dark, the film switches to the point
of view of one of the women as she uses her
camcorder's night vision feature.
Her gaze jolts back and forth between her
friends, when suddenly one of the creatures
is visible in plain sight behind one of them.
It's a perfect jump-scare and ratchets the
fear present in the film exponentially.
Home invasion
Few modern horror films have been as acclaimed
as It Follows, a tense film about a girl being
relentlessly pursued by a creature that takes
the form of other humans.
It's a brilliantly simple premise for a horror
film and it works extremely well, but the
home invasion sequence is easily the film's
standout moment.
The creature, which can only be seen by protagonist
Jay, arrives at Jay's house, where she and
her friends are posted up in hopes of capitalizing
on strength in numbers.
As the creature appears, she springs into
a panic, locking herself in her room, only
to soon be joined by her friends…and an
unusually tall man behind them.
It's found her, and the image it takes this
time is one of the most disturbing forms it
takes in the film.
'We all float'
Before it was the unstoppable box office force
of 2017, It was a lower-budget affair showcasing
a tour-de-force performance by Tim Curry as
Pennywise the Dancing Clown.
The remake is an exceptional piece of horror,
but when comparing how each film adapted the
most iconic moment from the novel they're
both based on, the original is head and shoulders
above the new version.
It comes down to Curry's performance.
"Aren't you going to say hello?"
He takes Pennywise's demeanor in a direction
that somehow feels even fresher today than
it did in 1990.
Everything he says feels so surreally out
of place that the audience can't help but
feel creeped out.
"They float, Georgie.
They float."
It's all tied together with the infamous final
shot of Pennywise's true form seeping through,
yellowed fangs and inhuman eyes.
It created a generation of kids who are still
afraid of clowns to this day, and this scene
is what started it all.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!